so now that we know how to unlock an
achievement let's make some progress
towards unlocking in incremental
achievement as you recall one of the
achievements we wanted to implement is
our scent to guess or achievement this
is an achievement that a player earns
for making 100 guesses and this is an
incremental achievement meaning that we
want the player to see that they've made
a certain amount of progress every time
they play the game and so let's get to
implementing that this process is fairly
similar to what we did before in my Chi
Minh manager I am going to i'm going to
create a method increment achievement
with ID and we'll have our nsstring
achievement ID say x amount whoops let's
get that colon in there 30 and we'll
have an int that will reflect our
progress and now we can implement this
method will go down here and once again
like before we're going to create a gpg
achievement object will call this one
increment me and we're going to call gpg
achievement achievement with ID and pass
in our achievement ID string and then
increment me instead of unlock
achievement with completion handler we
will say increment achievement num steps
with a completion handler now this
number of steps is the amount of
progress that we want to make towards
unlocking this achievement remember
we're doing this for our son a guess or
achievement where we want the user to
make 100 guesses so this will be the
number of guesses that the user has made
every game so might be seven then maybe
it'll be six then maybe will be 12 and
then four and so our number of steps by
which we want to increment this
achievement is the progress variable
that we pass in and then we have our
completion handler
and let's put this on a new line and
we're going to have three arguments
passed into our completion handler first
how we newly enlarged this lock this
achievement that is how we made enough
progress towards completing this
achievement that we've unlocked it
current steps is the number of total
steps that the player has now made as
reported by your system and error is if
there's any error now by the way if we
wanted we could leave this all blank and
you know everything will work just fine
the library will record everything and
it will display an achievement unlocked
toast when appropriate but just you know
so we can see what's going on we'll do
some logging here so if error will end a
slog got an error are incrementing in
achievement and will pass in our
localize description and otherwise if
newly unlocked and a slog her a newly
unlocked and I suppose in either case we
can NS log according to the system your
total progress is now % d steps and this
will be current steps close that up and
that's about it we now have a generic
method to make progress towards an
achievement let's go back to our game
model and we're going to increment this
achievement from our player guest method
now you might be tempted to just
increment this achievement here you know
every time the player makes a guess you
would call self dot achievement manager
incremented chipman by ID you know
whatever we're calling it by a mount one
however this will run you into trouble
and that's because when you call gpg
incremented chief montanes client will
actually go out onto the network and try
and make a network call
every time and if this were to happen
very frequently if a player were to make
a lot of guesses there is a chance that
your game could end up getting throttled
by our system for making too many
network calls this is probably in
contrast to game centers recommendation
where I believe they encourage you to
make progress towards achievements
constantly I'm pretty sure this is
because game centers on device client is
a much more aggressive about you know
caching and automatically batching
network calls then our client currently
is we're looking into making
improvements to ours in the future but
for right now our recommendation is not
to increment an achievement by one every
single time so here's what we're going
to do instead once the player has won a
game we're going to call self
achievement manager and we're going to
increment our send a guess or
achievement by the total number of
guesses that the player has made so
we're only making this achievement
increment call once per game instead of
once per guess and that will work out a
whole lot better both in terms of the
system not throttling your game and you
know your user's device not having to go
out onto the network every you know
every three seconds we can get our
achievement ID by once again going to
the developer console and and guess my
number go to my achievements and here's
my sent to guess or achievement copy
that will paste it in here yes it does
kind of bug me that these two strings
look nearly identical but but there you
go so now we can run this and it looks
like our build succeeded and go to our
application here
and check out our achievements once
again my sent by sent to get sorracchi
mint is still at zero percent but now
I'm going to play a game and I'm going
to make a few guesses so oops due to
some more guesses since six guesses and
I think this will be our seventh guests
and so we've hit our game over a call
let's look at what's happening in the
log here so we've got two notes messages
here on our console log this first one
according to the system your total
progress is now seven steps is what we
got back from our increment achieved
with ID call back so that means that we
didn't get an error newly unlocked is
false because this has not been unlocked
yet but we've now recorded our total
progress as seven steps and the second
message looks like you've earned this
one already is because we told the
system to try and unlock our first timer
achievement and that one has already
been earned by the way this is
completely normal programming style you
don't need to perform any special logic
on your side to detect whether the user
has earned this achievement or not yet
and you know perform an unlock all
depending on whether they have whether
they haven't you know from your
perspective I would encourage you to
just not worry about it feel free to
submit an achievement multiple times
either our client will catch it or the
server will catch it and say oh you know
it's okay the user is already here in
this and that's completely normal
behavior we don't expect you to perform
a lot of logic just to keep track of
this stuff and by the way if I were to
run this again
and I were to make a few more guesses
ooh you see I've made seven guesses and
in my incremented chipman twith ID call
back I'm seeing the call i'm specifying
the amount of progress is seven but what
gets returned back by the system is now
14 again i believe this is a unlike game
center where it's your clients job to
keep track of the total amount of
progress the user has made towards
unlocking an achievement play games all
you need to do is record the amount of
progress the user has made for that game
and the system will add up your
achievement progress for you so there we
go we have now successfully incremented
achievement as well as unlocked an
achievement we have two more
achievements to implement but before we
add those in I don't know about you but
it's kind of bothering me that we've got
our achievement IDs embedded right there
within the code so i think in our next
lesson we're going to clean this up a
little bit just get these out of here
and then we'll implement these last two
achievements so i'll see you soon
Wow
father but the fire
papa